good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Monday hope everyone's
having a glorious beginning to their
week they're Rising they're grinding
they're uh shining rise grass and Rise
Grand and Chad hey Jax how are you I'm
doing so well thank you so much so be
happy to be back on the ones and twos
with turdy even though I immensely
enjoyed the weekend alarm Free Living
even though my alarm is my son and it
goes off earlier than I could have ever
imagined my alarm is my son and my
husband is my rose
gorgeousness how is uh the love of my
life he's good he misses you but he's
doing his thing it was really tough you
know I saw a lot of great content this
weekend of Harry out at the zoo
and it was it was tough I'm not gonna
lie it's hard to see people out there
living your dreams you know yeah you
would have loved it I know actually you
know I have a thing against zoos I won't
go it wasn't oh shut up you no like it's
good for the kids but like you know it
wasn't a zoo it was a petting zoo which
is so different because when you think
Zoo you're like lions and tigers and
bears oh my there was pigeons and you
know like goats all really
domesticated animals yes yes okay there
wasn't any animal that should be living
in the wild okay okay so maybe your pro
petting zoo I think I don't know if
petting zoo makes me think of like a
circus like a birthday party like I
don't know if petting zoo is the right
word it's more of like a like a farm
yeah yeah it was a petting zoo Farm type
of thing goats chickens
okay okay I'll allow it yeah it was all
very Humane you know Harry would not
stand for anything
is a lover of animals especially
Beluga in the two blue say swim so wild
and you swim so free do you know about
um singing in cursive no
it's like a tick tock thing and it's
like yeah oh yeah it's like when you
like sing weird and like people can't
really it's called singing in cursive
that's what I was just doing and I hear
what you're saying when you say singing
in cursive that's not what I would
expect yeah no that's fair but that's
what singing in cursive because cursive
is like beautiful and elegant and that
was almost like Opera
cursive yeah yeah what you did is like
Comic Sans oh literally
I should have won Tick Tock where I'm
just so annoying and I correct Trends I
love that for you does anyone do that
that could be my niche
niche
Niche okay we'll use like pronouncing
that like to be quirky yeah to be quirky
and I do think some people pronounce it
that way yeah some people who are wrong
definitely pronounce it that way yeah
but it could be my Niche what do you
think does anyone do that
no not you could really get the handle
gen Z's big sis and you're just teaching
gen Z like how about everything how to
like understand words and stuff yeah and
just be like this
trend is not congruous with reality I'm
so sorry try again yeah no people would
love that like you being negative like
bringing people back down to earth I
love that I do kind of love that let me
tell you how exhausted I am
for the last 36 hours I know I haven't
gotten your weekend recap yet because I
can only hear it once because of the
seething jealousy that I feel so I
couldn't hear it like last night and
then again on the toes so I figured
obviously we all want to hear about your
weekend please letardia tell us about
your weekend Waking Up in Vegas
literia okay so I saw Adele on Saturday
night I literally woke up at 5am got on
a 7 30 flight it was delayed like don't
even get me started like I woke up at
five just had my flight delayed an hour
and it's like why everyone was there the
plane was there like they didn't say
they were just being slow and like not
conscious of people's times which I
thought was really disrespectful JetBlue
nevertheless we persisted I got there it
was like the longest day ever because I
had like a six hour flight and I landed
it was [__] 10 a.m or like 11.
um I got to the hotel I showered I went
to the spa I got a massage it was like
things were really working out for me
you know and then Margo called me and
she was like did you see Brian's stories
and I was like wait what and I'd like I
had like tapped through buying stories
just because like it was like a lot of
travel stuff and I was like getting my
hair done over the blow dryer I couldn't
hear so I was just like tapping through
and then I always see yeah no and then
I'm like oh my God Brian had been in
Denver for a work thing which is why we
decided to go because he was already
halfway there
um and the Vegas Airport was like shut
down like they were not letting in
inbound flight the weather there was a
lot of weather this weekend his flight
was delayed like getting him in at like
8 PM the show was at eight I was like
[__] and it was like [__] for a
multitude of reasons one because Brian
you know was going to miss the show and
two I was in Vegas alone no that's the
[__] yeah so I was thinking I'm like
what am I gonna do like do I go I'm like
yeah I go but I have these extra tickets
then I was thinking like okay maybe I'll
buy the tickets off of
Brian and like see if literally anyone I
know is in Vegas right now or I was
honestly thinking like maybe I'll take a
toaster like maybe there's a toaster
there for her bachelorette party I'll
take the bride you know like I was
really I didn't want to go by myself
so
I'm getting my hair done I really wasn't
like that worried the thing about Brian
is like he's gonna get where he needs to
go he's a travel expert so I was like
trying to come up with different plans I
was literally looking into like how much
you would cost a charter a plane and
Brian was like don't worry I got it he
flew into St George which is like an
airport in Utah that's about 90 minutes
maybe two hours from the strip he landed
got there at six
got ready at 6 30. we went down had
drinks like timing was perfect I don't
know why everyone was like I'll bent out
of shape like it was fine I was I don't
know why I wasn't even worried for a
second you know
but then once he got there like it was
balls to the wall like we just hit the
ground running we had cocktails we went
to the show and let me tell you about
this show
wow I have I have a lot of layered
thoughts I just want to start with the
show on its face
it was really it was beautiful it was it
was Sensational she's such a talent
she's so funny like one of my biggest
pet peeves is when people talk in
between songs like please just shut up
like shut up and sing not to be that
girl
I just find it like so boring and like I
don't care but Adele like she really
could do stand up and I think it's
because she's a formerly fat person and
formerly fat people like have to be
firing on all cylinders when it comes to
Talent personality like in order to be
like accepted by everyone it's like you
just have to be
funny and she really is oh my God she
was so funny and she was really kind of
blunt and she didn't you know Zoom past
the fact that like people who bought
tickets for this show when they went on
sale have had the tickets for 14 months
like people have been waiting a really
long time she didn't glaze past it she
gave her explanations and you know what
she basically said was like I didn't
think it was going to be good
the first time around like I needed more
time and you know what I totally
understand and respect that I think the
what we were told about like Vegas not
being able to have you know the
infrastructure to operate in the way
that she wanted I don't think that was
necessarily true because the show itself
was not
out of this world pyrotechnics Flames
dancers like it wasn't she didn't have
an alpha change like it was it was very
simple it's very stripped down very
Adele but in a Vegas way so
saying that Caesars like didn't have the
infrastructure to get everything done in
the time that's not necessarily true I
just think she wanted it to be amazing
and it was amazing and maybe she just
wasn't ready
14 months ago but it was amazing I mean
the set list she didn't get you know
creative like just sing the songs that
Everyone likes and she did her voice is
just unmatched like you didn't she had
dancers and there was like you know
moving stages and there was lanterns
coming down from this guy she didn't
even need all that but you know for
Vegas you do that but it was really so
special to see Adele she plays arenas
and it was so special to see her in such
an intimate setting I feel like you know
even in the very last row you had an
amazing seat it was very small it was
beautiful I loved it everyone there was
so excited and so like aware of the fact
that this was such a special opportunity
that not everyone's gonna get to see she
talked really candidly about how much
she loves doing it you know she spends
her weekends in Vegas she doesn't do
anything else the rest of the week she
loves it she lives in L.A it's like an
easy commute I feel like she should
continue to do more but it won't be as
special if it's like you know year round
and everything and then she becomes you
know like just like a Vegas Girl
staple and that's kind of the end of
people's road to be doing that it's like
retired yeah so I think like if if she
had to do more she would love it I don't
think she will because I think she's
very conscious of like you know she's
very strategic in her business yeah um
but it was incredible like it was
it was so good and she did songs you
know of your she cried a few times
especially talking about Hometown Glory
which is like a really old kind of Niche
song but she's like I just love singing
this song now because it reminds me so
much of like the life I used to have
when I could just like walk around and
be like a normal girl and go to my
hometown and go to the pubs and and she
got emotional a couple times especially
because the show that we saw was
supposed to be the last show of the
original residency like this was going
to be the finale but when they announced
that they were pushing it back they also
announced that they were going to be
adding another month because she was
like I can't just announce bad news like
I had to give the people something
um so it was just like emotional for her
it was emotional for everyone it was it
was amazing it was really special it was
very Vegas I loved every minute of it
and then of course afterwards you know
we hit the town we hit the casino it was
great it was a good twin I was really
glad that I went you know like when
Brian was almost not gonna make it I was
like this would happen to me like I said
yes to life I do something crazy and I
get [__] and I'm here all by myself
but he made it you know did you win
money yeah
so no I didn't but but it's important to
know like I
towards the end of the night like I was
down a lot like a lot a lot it was just
nothing was working in my favor it was
negative energy at the table
but then you know I just decided to go
like balls to the wall at the very last
second and I did like four hands in a
row of like a [__] ton of money
and I won
so I ended up only losing about 300
which for me is the cost of having a
good time in Vegas
so I'm happy so I like no I didn't lose
I didn't win but like I didn't really
lose you know yeah no I I think that
that's fair but it's like for so much of
the night it was stressful then that you
were losing no because that was like
blackout and I always have fun when I'm
gambling like for me if you gambling can
be so toxic but like if you can come at
it with like a leveled head and
understand like you're paying the price
of having fun like how much would I be
spending at a bar or a club and the
drinks are free you'd probably spend 300
in drinks in Vegas for over the course
like five six hours exactly so I felt
good about the decision and I have fun
like I really do enjoy gambling like I
love to get to know the people at the
table next to me I mean at the seats
next to me no one was like feeling my
energy I was like trying to you know
throw out great you know thought
starting questions at the table and the
guy next to me um like he was not vibing
at all like he was just there to make
money you know yeah no they don't want
to be thinking about anything other than
the game yeah you know what I was
throwing around I'm like who are your
guys's celebrity doppelgangers like I
was asking good questions
and he like he he was from Iraq and I
don't think he really understood like
the question and he was not like vibing
with me at all but then you know we did
find some common ground because I asked
him what he did he's like wholesale I'm
like okay give me more I'm like what
else like wholesale of what he was like
Vapes I'm like you're a vape magnate
like of course then that's like Common
Ground we were talking about you know
the license the legality he you know he
did warm up to me but it took a while
but turdy if you sat at a table and so
no kill me kill me other end it's like
so who's everyone's celebrity
doppelganger which is a concept that
you're
fundamentally against yeah you would
take her out back and shoot her I would
but even the deal the dealer liked the
question because she was totally a
Marissa Tomei look alike and I said I
said you get Marissa Tomei she's like
all the time like a young Marissa Tomei
what did you say for you
nobody asked that's the thing it's like
no one was interested like I was working
overtime to make the conversation flow
and like no one was throwing it back to
me it sounds like next time you need to
not go to Vegas alone
I wasn't alone I was with Brian and John
were they at your table yes Brian is a
really serious gambler like Brian
celebrity doppelganger oh that's a good
question
I know you were waiting for someone to
ask you I I actually I don't even have
one because people say beanie feldstein
but it's just
it's just not accurate especially now
that like I've lost weight like people
only I say this all the time if you've
seen me on tour and you watch my comedy
special I have a whole bit about like
how I only get paired to check I only
get compared to chubby brunettes
she's like now that I've lost weight
people don't know who to compare me to
well Victoria Fuller
row that's your celeb doppelganger
true
um so Brian's like a really serious
gambler like I know Brian hates when I
get all chatty at the table but like for
me that's the best part and when your
table is like when you feel connected to
the people at your table and you start
having camaraderie I'm telling you it
changes the cards like you're all
playing together and you're having fun
like your team but when you play with
Brian we play at like a a higher minimum
table like the five dollar ten dollar
tables is all fun but you play with
people who don't know how to [__]
play and they mess up the cards so it's
like it's toxic so with Brian sometimes
we pay like the 50 or 100 and that's why
like I can't keep up I'm like oh my God
100 each hand
so you're at a table with more serious
more focused people they don't want to
they don't want they're not interested
in the camaraderie and let me tell you
across the way there was this table I
was having such fomo of because every 10
minutes they were like oh look they were
all screaming they were all wearing
cowboy hats and I was like I gotta get a
seat at that table you know yeah that
was like the vibe and I was at like the
toxic serious probably like you know
degenerative people gambling you know
their kids tuition away and they were so
focused like they did not they did not
want to you know camaraderie with me it
sounds like you need to find a balance
between like you know the five dollar
people who don't know how to play in the
hundred dollar serious non-fun like
maybe the 25 50 table yeah good luck
getting a seat those are like the most
popular ones because everybody wants
like a decently you know a decent
minimum 25 50. but then they also want
people who know how to play and you'll
get that at the median tables so you
walk around it's like my choice are the
five dollar tables to play with people
who don't know how to play and are gonna
you know are gonna stay on a 12 against
us isn't there really just like one rule
of knowing how to play which is just oh
no
hit on 17. no no hit on 17 no you don't
want to gamble with me I'll tell you
that much yeah no because Jackie's like
let's just let the chips fall where they
may yeah and like once the money comes
out of the ATM like it's gone I don't
know it doesn't have to be I don't see
it coming back multiplying so then I'm
like well I have this money let's go
shopping instead that's more fun
yeah Jackie's so toxic to gamble with
like if you care about like the there
are there are there's a the book they
call it the book yeah but there's not
that many rules it's just okay when
you're on 17 what do you do
you never hit on a 17 unless it's a soft
17 like you have an Ace and a six
okay so there's the rule what else is
there but also it's so it's different
every time it's not just like hit on 12.
it depends what the dealer is showing
the dealer shows are less than you right
right right so if the dealer has like a
four or five or a six you'd think
they're gonna bust so no matter really
what you have you pretty much stay
unless it's below an 11. because let
that [__] bust not you what about you
know she has to take a card you don't
yeah
because she has to hit up until seven
teams exactly right so by the Dealer's
rules because dealer always wins
so you also they sell and that's how I
learned how to play they sell in most
Casino gift shops this little it's like
a it looks like a playing card it's one
card and it has a chart and it's
basically like here's what you have and
here's what the dealer has they'll tell
you what to do and it's like the book
so that's why I learned how to play and
people the higher you go to the minimums
like 50 table people know the book but
the people who are playing five dollars
aren't playing you know to to make a
[__] ton maybe they're just playing to
have fun they don't really know how to
play they don't gamble a lot so it could
be really treacherous because you don't
want them [__] up the Kurds no the
Kurds are everything everything so I
mean I'm exhausted
I got home at like eight o'clock last
night passed out but it was so worth it
I'm so glad that's like a saying yes to
life win amazing I'm so glad honestly
there's only four more weekends I would
definitely go back with you if you want
to I would try to go the way that you
did it just like in and out I feel like
I could do
no I didn't really get to like you know
go out to dinners honestly there's so
many well you could have gone to dinner
if Brian arrived on time yeah like if we
both took 7 30 flights like we could
have the afternoon yeah yeah Katy
Perry's residency was uh going on at the
same night Adele like said she wanted to
go
um
there's so many shows like I just I
would definitely go back if you wanted
me to okay let's we'll talk about it
we'll discuss we shall discuss I'm
thinking of speaking of things we need
to discuss I can't believe we've been
gone oh 17 minutes that disgusting what
a big day it is here at Spritz Society
slash toast slash toast slash share
media skinny confidential Enterprises
because today's the day we've been
annoying as [__] secret project well
here's the secret project reveal
if you're watching on YouTube Jackie's
holding it up we've decided many moons
ago to do a collab with Lauren Bostick
for a multitude of reasons we already
worked with Lauren and the skinny
confidential and Michael at Deer media
they are investors in Spritz we've
really started to work with them a lot
in the last year and so we've been
wanting to do like an influencer collab
on Spritz but we wanted it to be with
someone who has like a really engaged
Community who has like a really specific
brand and aesthetic and that's so Lauren
I mean pink skinny confidential so we
have our first ever collab with Spritz
it is with Lauren it is a pink lemonade
sparkling wine let me tell you it is the
it is Far and Away the best flavor it
really is which is crazy because it's
like a limited edition and once they go
they're gone it is so [__] tasty and
the the box is like so Lauren like if
you look on the side it's like in her
font best enjoyed ice [__] cold like
that's so Lauren yeah um yeah she writes
a little like letter on the box and on
the can it's like you can hear her or
saying it I listened to her podcast this
morning so I have her voice in my head
introducing your new favorite sparkly
pink cocktail that's right the skinny
confidential is serving up this
mouth-watering party in a can wait made
with real California white wine real
fruit flavors and best enjoyed ice
[__] cold it'll look so good on your
bark Heart Like Lauren made sure it was
aesthetically pleasing on brand for
everyone
um
Ben is on her podcast today I listened
to it this morning it was so funny and
they're just talking about obviously the
collab but also business entrepreneur
Michael and Ben remind me actually a lot
of each other they remind each other of
each other too there were a lot of
things they have in common on the
episode it was a really good episode and
they talk a lot about like the Genesis
so if you're interested in like branding
and just like you know very
entrepreneurial hustle Vibes they they
dive deep and if you want to get the
flavor you can
um what's cool about it is that Lauren
went to her audience and like asked him
a bunch of different questions on like
what you want the box to look like what
flavor you want how you wanted to taste
so it's really made by the skinny
confidential audience it's made with
real California white wine it has real
fruit flavors it's all natural you know
Lauren is serious about what she puts in
her body like this is TSC approved it
has the TSC
stamp of approval
like all the Spritz Society flavors it
has no artificial sweeteners it's
gluten-free it has 120 calories it has a
six percent ABV you can shop the new
limited edition packaging read the best
served ice [__] cold tagline
um when you go to sportsociety.com TSC
that's spritzociety s-p-r-i-t-z
society.com
TSC as in the skinny confidential we are
so excited for you to try it we are so
excited to be partnering with Michael
and Lauren I feel like every time like
we talk about them all we do is just
talk about like how much we love and
respect them and like their business
yeah and to have like something out in
the world with them is very very
exciting and it's also just more
importantly so [__] good like so
[__] tasty if none of them tastes
like a starburst if none of the rest
means anything to you you know the
collab the entrepreneurial ship the the
natural flavors the ABV percentage just
know it's [__] tasty it's so good I
tried it for the first time a few months
ago and it was like it's giving pink
Starbursts you know Sour Patch it's so
good it seriously is but it's not too
sweet like what you would think of pink
lemonade Starbursts it could be too
sweet it's not but it's it's perfectly
sweet it's refreshing yeah it's really
good I'm very excited for that to be out
in the world now and everyone to be able
to try it
um it's just like you know business
things business things this morning I
really enjoyed listening to their
podcast this morning and just like a
podcast I always say this every time I
happen to listen to another podcast
before our show like I should do it more
often because you could really just like
learn a lot from other people as people
and also as podcasters you know yeah I
loved listening to it I got it I got
ready uh listening to it as well and I
enjoyed it very much I also just loved
listening to podcasts where like I am
spoken about you know they actually
talked a lot about the toes my name was
in there a few times like that was
exciting it's like there I am yeah it's
nice to feel like personally vested in a
podcast in that way I don't know if I
enjoy listening to podcasts where they
don't talk about me actually the only
podcast we listen to are ones where
people talk about us we because people
send it to us they're like they're
talking about you at minute 29. yeah or
they don't tell you the minute they're
talking about you so you listen to the
whole thing waiting for them to talk
about you yeah that's fun like when
somebody DM me oh my God Tim Dylan
talked about you on his patreon oh okay
so let me sign up and pay eight dollars
to hear Tim Dillon call me fat okay
[__] I don't know why that person
messaged me like I would want to [__]
hear that yeah I'm like I'm gonna pay to
hear somebody I respect and admire call
me [__] fat [__] you're [__] fat
okay pot calling the kettle black [__]
he said it in an endearing way yeah he
did like he said it was a lot of respect
for you he wanted to actually partner
with you and trying to uh try and solve
some of the world's problems and he just
like happened to also yeah let me tell
you why let me tell you why it was her
fault to be called that
tip one because I had to pay for it and
it's like okay I could you know log on
to Reddit and see people calling me fat
for free so I don't need to I don't need
to you know put this on a business
expense one that's true
what was my second Point hold on I had a
good one
it was hurtful excited to pay for it
I think I know the second point but I
don't want to like assume I don't want
to assume but I think purple based on
you know how I remember it and there was
no no I remember can I guess no no no
I don't want you to beat me to the
punchline it's funny okay fine
let me set the scene for you guys where
I'm at in my life this is what I was
gonna say
you know I'm feeling good I had lost
like 25 pounds and I'm like on this
health kick I feel you lost more maybe
maybe I'm halfway through my journey
like I've made significant progress in
my life I thought maybe I'm past the
point of people Rogue calling me fat
Maybe
uh no somebody I think is so funny and
like really like their content is out
here call me fat it's like okay you want
to call me fat before like all right
it's kind of mean but it's not entirely
inaccurate but now it's like I'm not
even that fat I'm like more chubby now
maybe overweight is what you could call
me and I'm being called that like that
that was purple and you know I wanted to
come on the podcast like the next day
and like ripped him [__] Dylan a new
[__] but you know he's so funny he's
so funny
for me like one of the most unforgivable
sins in the world is calling someone fat
like it's so mean
um and I'm I'm here and I'm kind of
unbothered like I still like really
think he's funny and it was it was tough
because I'm grappling with being such a
big fan but like does it help at all
that he said it in like in a loving way
like he wasn't like that some people
have like gotten a package to be like
that
yes and it's like Jesus Christ yeah yeah
he would say like hey like he was he was
saying it as a descriptor and like I
feel like you have a lot of um affection
for the word chubby like it's just not a
word that bothers you you find it to be
like cute and yeah like maybe that's how
he feels about the word fat like I don't
think he knew that it would cut you to
your core I don't think he knew no it
could even more given that like I was on
this journey you know of of weight loss
here's the thing he hasn't apologized
but I forgive him you know he doesn't
It's just tough like he doesn't hear
your feelings he doesn't even know what
I listened to it because it was behind a
paywall he probably thought I would
never hear it but like one thing about
me when they say oh this person talks
about you on their podcast I'm gonna
listen to the whole thing just to hear
the four seconds and in the future if
you're gonna DM me Oh blank spoke about
you on their podcast send a timestamp
[__] okay I have a lot of [__] going on
I can't be like listening to hours of
podcasts send a timestamp okay and if
they use the f word maybe trigger
warning not even uh you two want to know
if someone calls you fat on their
podcast or you just don't want to know
about it period
I'm gonna find out anyway like
I don't know only one person message you
that if they didn't message you it you
would have never known yeah because who
the [__] would message me something like
oh they spoke about you they was
obviously calling me fat like why would
you tell me that that person was an
enemy except that like we loved him
Dylan we had so much respect for him and
like he was talking about you and like
in a otherwise nice way and wanting to
collab with you I know like if you had
told me like somebody would go on their
podcast which by the way he's like one
of the biggest creators on patreon like
he's huge it's not he was not chatting
into a void it's you know thousands of
people so if you had show me somebody
called you fat on their podcast and like
you still follow them and engage with
their content and like them like I would
have never believed you but like and
also you know obviously Tim Dylan is no
spring chicken he's pretty big himself
so to hear you know it coming from a
fellow member of the fat community
I I don't know it definitely lessened
the blow I don't know it's something I
definitely struggle with yeah I I
understand
but like I'm I never unfollowed him like
if anybody else called me fat like oh my
God death to them we write a dawn but
there's something about Tim Dylan that's
just he's so funny like I just I can't
actually asked him you'd only be like
hurting yourself if you cut him off
because then you wouldn't get the funny
content I love his reels like I'm always
sending them to you I'm always sending
them to you yes like whoever sees it
first
so I'm just I'm gonna have to move past
you know maybe Tim Dylan will hear this
and shoot me an apology which would go a
long way but I don't even need it that's
how like that's how much of a fan I am
you know yes it's you know what Tim it's
okay
yeah but it's not like it's not [__]
okay [__] call me fat again see what
[__] happens [__]
call me [__] fat again
I thought me and Tim were good he
actually invited me to a barbecue at his
house I was like oh my God I'm getting
in Tim's Inner Circle
and then this the f word it's so someone
cool life is so unfair yeah just when
you think you're getting somewhere with
someone they go [__] call you fat
on a podcast nonetheless safe space I
think yeah patreon safer space yeah you
know I think he thought I would never
hear it you know and that's okay
um
I'm okay that's you know what I'm okay
she survived I survived
she's a survivor
I am
it was tough Claudia listen do a flip
no we're always quoting him here you
don't [__] [__] okay [__] you I'm
bad it was I was so mad in the moment
but then like
Time Heals all wounds yeah no but I'm
like a bitter [__] like I hold grudges
and with Tim like
I've let it go yeah I can't quit you Tim
some people I really hold grudges like I
will tell you what they did five years
ago I will quote it verbatim other
people could have fed me last week and I
forgot already
you know it's like he's just this
charismatic guy he's got this way about
him this is
he does I have a gym as well so I'm
moving on and letting go yeah I'm Moving
On Letting Go holding on to tomorrow
I've always got the memories that it
keeps me where I'm gonna be I'm so glad
Hannah Montana wrote that song for me in
these trying times Fifth Harmony also
wrote a song about you called miss
moving on
you know because I am Miss momentum
totally I'm so Fifth Harmony you're
Sixth Harmony no Camilla left so
hey guys turdy's here
dirty is here I often think about like
the utter disaster that was Fifth
Harmony's career
there was like no reason they they were
so
tacky like everything they did was like
so low budget but they were so talented
and they had such good songs that was
like the only thing carrying them
through the songs were bops but like
when when I see footage all the time on
Tick Tock of like you know their
comeuppance and they're doing these like
shows and malls on these like broke down
stages being held together by a piece of
duct tape like they were on this big
show they had Simon Cowell behind him
there was like no reason everything they
did was so beyond low budget yeah I also
feel like and this is based on
interviews that I heard from them like I
feel like they didn't make any money
from it it's like their songs were
number one on the radio number one on
the charts like you couldn't walk down
the street without hearing their music
and they were not making money yeah
because they're like the prime example
of like getting taken advantage of like
very young girls like just signing a
record deal not getting a ton of money
and then having to split it five ways oh
yeah so they really they made I think
you know a lot of them have nothing to
show financially from their time during
in that in that band yeah plus then once
you're at that level it's also expensive
to live at that level right the style is
the publicist style hair security like
yeah the money just goes out the window
no it's so true that's why they're all
doing their own things now like
different projects a lot of them are
like influencer Vibes I love that I love
an influencer Vibe yeah no it's a really
interesting case study and what not to
do after X Factor
but
what's the alternative say they were
like no this is a bad contract then they
would just be defunct X Factor true
expats so true x x fats oh no no no no
no I was trying to say factor and expat
you guys know what I meant expat yeah I
like that yeah
so with if that's everything I think we
could dive in yeah we've we have stuff
to discuss we have stuff to discuss so
let's dive into the past five stories
that you need to know
imminently
and the past size story is that you need
to know imminently is brought to you by
Babel one of the most exciting things
about a new year is that you have no
idea what Adventures are in store for
you especially if like me you're saying
yes to life from new travel experiences
to new jobs or picking up skills there's
no better way to prepare for 2023 than
by learning a new language with Babel
Babel is the language learning app that
has sold more than 10 million
subscriptions and thanks to Babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons you can feel confident
no matter where the New Year takes you
with Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks so
whether just learning a new language is
something you want to do this year or
you have trips coming up and you want to
you know get a little bit like the
Baseline of the language just so you can
feel confident and safe walking around
there's really so many good reasons to
get started on Babel because other
language learning apps use AI for their
lessons lesson plans but Babel lessons
were created by over 150 language
experts they're voiced by real native
speakers and not computers you can
choose from over 14 different languages
Plus their speak speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and accent there are so
many ways to learn Babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcasts Games
videos stories and even live classes it
comes with a 20-day money-back guarantee
so right now you can get up to 55 off
your subscription when you go to
babel.com toast that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com toast for up to 55 off
your subscription Babble language for
Life today's episode is also brought to
you by Squarespace
so Squarespace is really everything from
websites and online stores to marketing
tools and analytics Squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business so
whether you have a side hustle you want
to start an e-commerce business really
Squarespace is the best place to start
because they've got e-commerce they've
got you know really integrated ways to
connect your social media you'll own all
your content they have a Squarespace
one-click data portability so it's
really the best place to start
if you're looking to get into website
building and you don't have a lot of
background in like software engineering
or computer science or website building
I have built many websites over the
years for like blogs e-commerce and I
can tell you Squarespace from experience
is really the best they make it so easy
they'll give you really good insights
into your traffic overview and your
analytics so if you want to get a free
trial
um use squarespace.com toast and then
when you're ready to launch you can use
the offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
that's squarespace.com toast for the
free trial and then offer code toast to
save 10 percent 10 off your first
purchase they also have great product
features like email campaigns you can
collect donations you can share on
social you'll have great blogging tools
so if you're into blogging you can
connect your content to Facebook Twitter
Google Plus LinkedIn Reddit Pinterest
Tumblr all the great places again that's
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to Launch
use the offer code toast to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain that is code toast
thank you turdy you're welcome I think a
sneeze is upon me oh let it out girl I
don't know it's like so far away it's a
distant sneeze and now I jinxed it
there's nothing there's no hell on Earth
greater than being teased by a sneeze I
was teased I'm so sorry thank you thank
you for your thoughts during this time
you're welcome first story the SAG
Awards were last night neither charity
nor I watched but two moments stood out
to me as worth discussing great
Aubry Plaza went viral after getting
caught losing her temper on stage during
the White Lotus I saw okay
so I'll replay this is going viral after
the SAG Awards where she got caught
losing her temper during two separate
moments when her White Lotus co-stars
accepted the SAG Award for best ensemble
in a drama series on Sunday night uh the
actress was caught looking annoyed and
pissed off as she stood alongside Theo
James Megan Fahey and will sharp and
fellow actor John gries John
um is seen Whispering something into her
ear which made her look Furious so the
whole cast went up to accept the award
for best cast and um he says something
to her people believe that he was trying
to warn her that she's about to have a
wardrobe malfunction because if you saw
her dress like that seems likely and she
because she immediately adjusted her
gown to cover her cleavage but then
after that
she appeared to awkwardly mouth Jesus
Christ under her breath and just look
overall pissed especially during a
winning moment this is so tough because
like Aubry Plaza is always like
committed to some bit she's always being
like quirky or like I don't know she's
always like doing something she's so
[__] hard to read so this could have
been part of like some bit you know
she's always just like doing the most or
she could have been like legitimately
peeved I don't honestly I don't know
because she's she's honestly she's
[__] confusing I never know she's
being serious or not yeah I don't know
her on that level like I'm not a fan
enough to like know what she's doing and
why she's doing it I just don't know
what like what sort of bit makes you act
like annoyed when you're in the midst of
a celebration joyous win
um
I don't I don't know I don't know either
I really
um I find her incredibly confusing like
to read she's always like you know
doing something and it's like everyone
thinks it's funny and I'm like I don't
get it kind of her comedy is very like
dead dry straight yeah
so was this that question mark
I don't know
I will say I feel like the SAG Awards
when it comes to award season are like
the irrelevant ugly like who [__]
cares I don't even know people watched
it but everyone really showed up last
night everyone looked really glamorous
and I found like there was a lot of
chatter on social media about it when I
feel like what everyone decided to get
together and watch the SAG Awards like
not tell me no I feel like the SAG
Awards always come up it's like okay
this is the relevant one but I feel like
people in the industry actually really
like the awards there's something like
very legit about it everyone shows up
for it I'm also getting very sick of
like this rotating cast of characters
that we've seen all throughout Awards
season like it's the same 20 people it's
like Angela Bassett Jamie Lee Curtis
it's everyone in the song yeah everyone
in this song after this like needs an
oriented boast was there I know that's
our second moment
um everyone in the song like I know
they're on the circuit right now but the
circuit seems like longer than ever and
it's really just like the same people
and like there are people who were on it
last year who are you know nowhere to be
found like usually this would be like
Jennifer Lawrence or Margot Robbie and
now it's just like
other people
um even like I mean Jennifer Coolidge
looked amazing last night and I love her
and I can never get sick of her but it's
like where's she gonna be next year like
no I I want to say that this year I
don't want to see you next week the SAG
Awards are nice because and it's similar
to the Golden Globes where it's it's
film and TV so I find like a lot of like
the exclusively film events bafta Oscars
those are like a little more boring but
when you know the White Lotus cast shows
up and people from like succession like
that's fun yes I so I feel like the sags
actually get uh an irrelevant reputation
but are pretty cool I think people in
the industry enjoy going to them and
respect them and if you ever take the
time to watch the show it's probably
better than Golden Globes or Oscars like
because there's a little less pressure
yeah I've always regarded it as very
much like an industry event that like
happens to be televised and like who
cares but I feel like in recent years
you're right it's kind of becoming like
a cool event yeah I feel like you've
even watched sometimes in the past and
you're always just like surprised by how
much you enjoy it but I also think
that's because the bar so low yes yes
Jennifer Coolidge gave a really funny
and cute speech she's also like always
doing some sort of bit but I felt like
last night she was being really
authentic she was talking about her
parents
um I think she got choked up a little
bit and then of course she like ended it
with a joke because she's Jennifer
Coolidge but you're right I think
everyone feels really relaxed when they
go because it's it's an industry thing
yeah so uh wait Lotus one yeah
still thinking about watching it Brendan
Frazier won
yes which is good I do think sags really
do set the stage for Oscars like I I do
think there's a lot of crossover in the
winners
I don't know I feel like we've gotten to
a place where maybe in the past you
could have said that but now it's just
like everybody will take home one award
from award season and that yeah we're
all winners you know like we really
we're all winners Austin Butler is like
still
doing the thing like yeah I'm ready for
the next chapter is all I'm saying no
you're right it's definitely feels
lengthy lengthy at length
at length and then also at the SAG
Awards another fun moment was Ariana
Dubose poking fun at her viral Baptist
rap while presenting at the awards so
she presented alongside Diego Luna and
she said Diego do the thing and they pan
to Angela Bassett and then when they
came back to Ariana it looked like she
was doing the shoulders and it was also
um this weekend the NAACP image Awards
and Angela Bassett won and she came up
and she said I guess I did the thing so
it's like everyone's and you know what
there's no better way to kill a moment
than by everyone doing it yeah so you
know what I think Ariana getting in on
it Angela getting in on it like I don't
think it's funny anymore Lisa got in on
it at her yeah I'm ready to move on and
you know what Ariana's probably happy
about that the thing is an unintended
consequence I'm ready to move on from
Angela Bassett did the thing because
everybody's doing that part but there
are so many other nuggets from it like I
know Blanchette Kate you're a genius
Jamie think Curtis you are all you are
all of us
I don't get that exception yeah let's
hyper fixate let's hyper fixate on some
other moments because there's there's
more noteworthy moments in there too
yeah and a girl you were great and
blonde and she wasn't
so that was cool I think she was really
good but the movie wasn't as good as
they think it was yeah yeah what were
you gonna say about Jamie Lee
she's a children's book that I like that
I read to Harry sometimes wear to
balloons really yeah it's really good
what's it called where do balloons go
it's like cute conceptually about when
you
um let go of your balloon where does it
go and it's like and where does it it
just it theorizes about all these
different like fun things the balloons
they meet up Ken Balloons with no
writing read the ones that have writing
on them where did where do they end
um I think like they go into space they
go on and on and then by the end I'm
always like oh is this a metaphor for
loss
oh you know what it does sound like it
might be that's actually a really great
concept for a book yeah that's always I
don't know if because you would think
like where the balloons go it's gonna be
like some environmental lesson about
like not to let go of your balloon it
gets stuck in the tree and bird chokes
but no I think it's about loss like
where do they go beautiful they keep
going up and they're having a party a
dance party and then eventually other
balloons they go into like the space I
kind of love that it's really and it
Rhymes which are the only kind of books
I'm willing to read because the rest are
no fun let's talk about this trend in
children's book I realized it when I
became an auntie it's like you know I am
a pentameter and and rhyming is no
longer a requirement and I think that's
beyond beyond disgraceful yeah no it's
what are we teaching our children no
it's like it's just so unfun
no and it's like I'm gonna have to read
this book one million times to my
[__] kid like let me have a good time
like let's get a beat in there right and
also once you've written it one million
times you haven't memorized that way
when they keep fussing with the pages
you don't have you can just keep going
yeah and you're not like seriously
stalled like what happens next right so
I just think I don't know who I need to
talk to but we need to get rhyming like
back in style yeah if anyone can do it
30 it's us so true so true anyways check
out that book I I really liked it
um Jamie Lee won she gave Michelle yo
like an enormous kiss on the lips that
was like more than it was just really
big like it was long hmm
yeah
it was cute I I like their friendship a
lot yeah I haven't seen that movie
oh but what I was going to say was Jamie
Lee is like you know obviously on this
press circuit so a lot of her interviews
have been like making news she did stand
up for Ariana Dubose when she was asked
about it she was like everyone needs to
just like shut the [__] up and back the
[__] off and like leave Ariana alone
which I thought was really cool of her
and
um she has said that while there's no
official plans like there will be a
Freaky Friday sequel like there's
nothing in the works I saw she said
there's nothing in the works no plans no
contracts no deals but like it's
happening to me that's a no-brainer
Lindsay Lohan is the mom Jamie Lee's the
grandma there's a new kid on in the
block yeah and maybe the three of them
like each get switched yes or like
Lindsay Lohan and her daughter gets
switched and Jamie Lee helps him
navigate through it like or like Jamie
or Jamie and Lindsay do it again and the
kid they have to act cool in front of
the kid like there's a million ways this
could go yeah it's just like they had to
act cool for him the little brother
right right and Chad Michael Murray of
course he him and Lindsay get married
oh of course and Chad Michael Murray is
like kind of like you know taking a lot
of low budget projects these days he's
available he's available
this one writes itself a hundred percent
are you ready for our next story
yes yes I am Royal pop culture news my
favorite oh this is [__] interesting
King Charles's Carnation is in crisis as
Elton John the Spice Girls and other top
musical acts declined his invitation to
perform so with the Carnation of King
Charles III just two months away reports
are emerging that the event is having a
difficult time lining up entertainment
according to the express a star-sided
concert is being planned at Windsor
Castle to follow the ceremony at
Westminster Abbey however organizers are
having a hard time booking the big
British Stars so far Elton John the
Spice Girls and Harry Styles have been
asked and have all declined but as the
sun pointed out it's reportedly nothing
personal simply that their artists
schedules are jam-packed you can
cross-reference that Elton is on tour
he's in like Germany the night before
and Harry Styles is always on tour so
it's like it really is two months away
like you could just go to
harrystyles.com tour and yeah check it
out they're not lying um other A-list
British pop stars to have reportedly
turned down the event include Ed Sheeran
Adele and Robbie Williams
performers who are expected so far are
Kylie and Danny Minogue Andrew Lloyd
Webber and Lionel Richie
oh okay it's just not great but it's not
terrible no but like if I was a big
British
star which you kind of are which I kind
of am but I guess I'm not a singer I'm
just like a kind of like a big British
Personality yeah yeah like kind of like
you're giving like Pierce Morgan energy
yeah yeah like like a famous British
talking head 100 I would move Heaven and
Earth to get my ass there I know and I
know well elton's older so it's
different he used to show in Germany the
night before like if it were Harry with
his show in Germany the night before
like
he could get a plane and fly in for this
like if Elton also has been involved in
so many Royal events in the last 20
years that I don't think this one like
stands out in particular it's like he's
done a million he'll probably do more
yes but a carnation is a once in a
lifetime thing especially when you know
Queen Elizabeth reigned for so long most
of us haven't I mean obviously us but
like I don't even know if Elton John was
alive for Elizabeth's Carnation right
so it's it's not just like you know it's
the to the Centennial like it's a car
Nation so it's a historic day uh I
understand people are busy I wish they
like thought about that when you know
they had this date on the books for a
while like why are we just now reaching
out to people but by the way there's
also this intersection of you know
British celebrities and British
celebrities who are friends with Harry
and Megan and I feel like Adele is
probably like friendly with them I don't
know why she just like she reminds me of
that like you know Ellen Kris Jenner
Montecito like Rich Inner Circle yeah
but I think that there's also British
celebrities who are either like
royalists or like anti-monarchist and I
think that if Adele was you know a
fervent royalist
um
that would also affect her relationship
with Harry and Megan I don't I should go
and look for any interviews where she's
maybe like talked about how she feels
about the queen or whatever
um not no just like the queen because I
feel like that's you know british
talking points but everyone I think even
if you weren't a monarchist everyone
loved and respected the queen and the
cheating performance Jubilee Adele yeah
but Jubilee is not as historic as like a
car Nation like you were saying yeah but
it was like very clear that this was
gonna be like the last big Queen event
but they pulled it out for the Jubilee
and none of these people performed for
Jubilee either except for Elton John and
so like they had British artists large
mid-sized small I loved seeing some of
the smaller Ellie Goulding I know I was
thinking about Ellie Goulding but she
performed in how are you Megan's wedding
never mind
um
no I'm telling you it's tough to find
honestly people are like shocked that
they that they can't find someone but
when you really think about the group
it's like okay we have singers British
singers British singers who like the
monarchy and don't have like personal
politics you know I'm not British but I
imagine like you either fall into some
category like a monarchist or not Marcus
right so then you then you have to be a
monarchist then you have to be a
monarchist who's not siding with Harry
and Megan then you have to be a
and Megan who's not currently on tour
and it's technically available on May
6th so I think people are like oh
everyone hates Charles like hey they're
not performing and maybe there's an
element of that but I also think it's
not so easy
yeah but it also like should be a little
easier because he's the king I
definitely I definitely think there's an
element of just also people not liking
or respecting Charles yeah especially
because of them being like Diana Stans
as well right so like if this was
William's coronation I don't think there
would be I think Little Mix would be
having a reunion performance and William
Prince Prince William has hung out with
and you know actually sang a song with
Taylor Swift and and John Bon Jovi like
I think he's got deep ties in Hollywood
yeah
I feel like King Charles has he's been
literally a famous
World figure his whole life I feel like
people don't like him Hollywood friend
no but he's so like
Hollywood weirdly not as much as like
Harry and Megan at this point but like
yeah he's been
at the A-list since he was born and now
he's 70 what like you know I just feel
like people don't like him
I hope that they bring Adam Lambert and
the remaining members of queen that was
really good always to smash it I hope
they bring Neil Diamond to sing Sweet
Caroline so that we could see George
singing along again yeah do you think
they have to be British yeah like Taylor
Swift
you know she loves a London boy and she
like has a house in London obviously her
boyfriend's British like I don't know I
think there's a time I think Taylor
Swift could do it Lionel Richie is he
British no you're right so I think that
they don't have to be British but they
do need some of the big British Acts
because like this is a big moment for
Britain yeah yeah you're right
Little Mix
get together
yeah Ed Sheeran was surprisingly like
absent from the Jubilee
but isn't Ed Sheeran Scottish
is he
let me just double check because if
you're from Scotland like you don't
really [__] with the royal family yeah
yeah there's a lot of history there
no I'm sorry he's English I take that
back he was born in West Yorkshire and
raised in framlingham
so that Olly Murs what about that guy
who's saying hi Jackie I did read that
Olly Murs is performing like they're
like they can't get anyone good so they
got Olly Murs that's what I read on
Twitter that's all you need
you need Olly Murs you need Mimi Webb
you gotta strive for a little mix
reunion the guy who sang that song that
was like the wrong song to sing and they
even left out this the green green yes
blue blue sky yeah George Ezra performed
that song and the lyrics go you better
throw a party on the day that I die
which was like a weird select but he did
sing it like this Green Green Grass blue
blue sky you better throw a party
that's how he sang it
pick a different song I know but that
and actually that's not even his most
famous song like he's really known for
my house
Treasure Chest
yeah everyone knows that singing
I'm talking about you like that's like
his biggest song so I did that was a
weird select for sure for her sure
because the Jubilee was literally
throwing a party on the day that she
died she wasn't even at the concert
because it was weird like too tired and
frail
it was a really really Bizarre song
Choice especially given the fact that
it's not his biggest song it's like if
you got one big hit okay you gotta sing
the hit but literally Budapest is 40
times bigger yeah I do see um I went to
the express article and I see that Olly
Murs um
is filling in some of the gaps I'm
obsessed I love Ollie Mars This is a
concert meant for me it's just like
mid-tier British Artist which is
actually my favorite genre of music it's
so true
can't wait they need a big headliner
they got to figure it out yeah they do
Taylor will be on tour oh she'll be in
Nashville
yeah May 6th since his birthday weekend
yeah should be in Nashville can't do it
see
yeah and these schedules are lined up
years before Charleston to become king
until a few months ago right right so
even if they got to work immediately
there's genuine conflict yeah
they have to figure something out in
terms of like a big name they need one
big name it's a coordination like I
wonder if anyone in the royal family
like sings as a hobby
there's got to be one good choice
question there's got to be one good
voice the odds there's what like 20
working members there's got to be one
who do you think Camilla Parker Bowles
that's so something Charles would do
like you know my wife has like an
amazing voice and she sings like the
British national anthem or whatever that
is something Charles would do but like
what about like Prince Edward's wife
Sophie
I think she might have an amazing voice
there's definitely somebody who's like
got a good party trick you know hey I
could sing yeah what about Susan Boyle
bring her out bring her out National
Treasure love that love it
love I think we've given you some great
ideas
um car Nation planning committee take
with them what you will yeah
this isn't a good look for Charles like
it's like kind of embarrassing this
article coming out like he's so they
need to show up with like a good they
have to just they have to pay they have
to figure something the [__] out yeah I
gotta get Beyonce or something like come
on even though Beyonce loves Megan
true
true according to Megan but there's so
many big stars in the world like even
though it feels like a small community
like there's just so many and a lot of
them are British
yeah or you know they could
they could figure out a song to sing
they could do a cover they could do a
flip
do a flip
yeah so good luck I look forward to
watching this concert I really do
uh are you ready for our next story
circling back to someone who's come up a
number of times in this conversation now
Adele is rumored to be engaged to Rich
Paul you know what you saw she was
wearing
at the show but she's also wearing like
a lot of diamonds and a lot of rings but
she was wearing like a big ass she was
wearing an engagement ring on her
engagement ring finger and sometimes
like we look into like oh my God are
they secretly married and it's like
right here she is sitting down with her
ring on her finger although I will say
on Saturday night she did reference uh
she was talking about sports and she's
like I love basketball because my
boyfriend loves basketball so she said
boyfriend okay well two things are a
theory one she hasn't gotten used to
saying the word fiance when you go from
boyfriend to fiance fiance seems like
such a pretentious word it took me a
while to be very comfortable two she
didn't want to like spoil her news she
just wanted to like dangle it I do find
it surprising though that she would want
to get married again
yes well just because if you listen to
her music like I think she feels so sad
that she got divorced and like like
uneasy on me like she like she almost
sounds like disappointed in herself so I
just find it surprising because divorce
is not something that she took lightly
like I think she did everything in her
power not to get divorced this is like
still rumored um this is Daily Mail and
they're citing dumois as the
confirmation for her being engaged but
she did wear an engagement ring and she
does have a very serious boyfriend and
even though I feel like when she first
got divorced she would be like oh she's
scarred she's not gonna do this again
like I feel like her and Rich Paul are
so serious she is
as successful if not more successful
than her so like they'll be able to like
legally you know be and just be married
to be like romantically married and I
feel like she's a believer in marriage
and that's why it hurts so much that it
didn't work out it kind of reminds me
right now of Kelsey ballerini where it's
like I don't think she is off on
marriage period I could see her in a few
years being like no I I wanted that like
I tried for it it was just not the right
person
this is the right person and I do like
the institution let's do it totally
random but I just remembered something
that Adele shared at the show that I
want to share
um because my favorite Adele song is
turning tables and she was like this is
just like weirdly a fan favorite song
like it's really not even like her
biggest song but I'm so glad it was on
the
um on the set list and she said my I
think that out that was on 21 or 25 21.
she was like I used to have such good uh
song titles like I feel like as I've
gotten older like I'm getting worse at
coming up with song titles and the
reason I called The Turning Tables is
because we had this big fight the person
I was in a relationship with at the time
with this big fight at a Chinese
restaurant and there was like a lazy
Susan
um and we were fighting and he wouldn't
pass me the food
and I was like screaming to pass the
food turn the table and honestly I
thought she was kidding at first and she
was like no that's literally why it's
called Turning Tables because of the
Lazy Susan at the Chinese restaurant
Queen
that's really funny I know and just like
a fun fact about one of my favorite
songs yeah now thinking of her new song
titles
oh my God love is a game
they're kind of like corny
but easy on me is good yeah
she opens the show with a with hello and
she just like sauntered out it's not
like this big dumb like you know Shadows
Silhouettes like she just saunters out
in the sky and there's a man playing the
piano and it's so
amazing because you know I don't know if
you've seen the show but the whole
stadium not Stadium sorry the whole
theater is like covered in screens so
you could see her no matter where you
look in these big screens so she sings
Hello and it's like very slow and then
when she opens the chorus hello from
finally the screens go on and her face
pops up everywhere and it was like
honestly it was chilling it was
beautiful and then she says by the way I
just want to let you know like I do an
acoustic set like the first couple of
songs and then like there are singers in
a band like it's not just me sitting
here with the piano the whole time I
didn't postpone 14 months just to sit
here with the acoustic piano so it was
actually very funny she was being very
self-aware she wasn't like glazing over
the fact that like people had been
heavily inconvenienced yeah I feel like
I'm like seeing this I feel like now if
I saw the show I'd be like I already
heard that you know I feel like you're
giving me yeah sorry sorry I'll stop no
no but likely like if I had to you know
place a bet and gamble I would say the
odds are you're not gonna make it like I
would love to but like I don't know that
I will so I guess it's better to know
what happens yeah like
anyways if they are engaged congrats and
I believe that they could be
Meteo it's not it's not crazy they've
been together for a decent amount of
time too yeah but also sometimes like
when you don't want to get married again
but like you have your life partner you
get them a ring yeah and you just like
are engaged in this like partnership for
years yeah there's no like there's not
gonna be a wedding or anything but like
we are partners and I I wear yeah yeah
so it could be that ready for our next
story it's the next story that's brought
to you by Starbucks per chance yes it is
life moves fast Starbucks ready to drink
coffee delivers an uplifting boost that
helps you tune into the moments that
matter wherever you are so it is
Starbucks Coffee conveniently packaged
for life on the go it includes a variety
of beverages from the bottled
Frappuccino coffee drink for a pop of
flavor to the Bold smooth Taste of the
Nitro cold brew bottled Frappuccino
chilled coffee drink is inspired by
Starbucks cafe favorites and it comes in
four delicious flavors mocha vanilla
caramel and coffee you can enjoy every
moment with Starbucks ready to drink
coffee
um I have Starbucks ready to drink
beverages in my house in the studio
because you guys know when I went on my
coffee journey I really ended up only
really liking the Starbucks ready to
drink drinks that they sell so
um I love the range whether you want to
grab a Starbucks frappuccino chilled
coffee drink or the Nitro cold brew
which is what I keep in the studio
there's so many good choices for
whatever mood that you're in
um it's a Starbucks coffee with a pop of
flavor that makes our day so much better
wherever we are so you could shop the
full lineup online or in store wherever
you buy your groceries they really have
it everywhere I have such an easy time
finding it I first tried it Jackie major
shout out you introduced me to the line
of Starbucks ready to drink I was just
like you know I'm not a coffee girl and
now I had one this morning I really
could not do the toast without one of
these beverages add to the list of
things I convinced you on so true
Starbucks coffee ready for right now
shop the full lineup online or in store
wherever you buy groceries that's
Starbucks Coffee it is so good and thank
you Starbucks for sponsoring this next
story thank you this next story is very
sad
Hayden Panettiere's family confirms that
her 28 year old brother jansen's cause
of death was an enlarged heart so last
week it was revealed that uh Hayden
Panettiere Panettiere's younger brother
passed away and a statement from the
actress family confirmed that he died
from an enlarged heart quote though it
offers little Solace the medical
examiner reported Jansen setting passing
was due to cardio megaly enlarged heart
coupled with aortic valve complications
um
the statement concluded that they
sincerely appreciate the outpouring of
love and support towards their family as
they navigate this Unthinkable loss and
ask that they be gifted their privacy
during this time of mourning also
Hayden's brother Jensen was an actor
himself he was in Even Stevens uh The
Walking Dead and a bunch of other stuff
he was in 2022 he was in a holiday film
so I it's so sad and I really
I often think about like and feel sad
for Hayden Panettiere I feel like she's
been through so much in her personal
life since her rise to fame like
obviously there's like really bizarre
situation with her boyfriend and like
the domestic violence and then her
situation where her daughter lives with
her father
um she had really bad postpartum
depression she like sought treatment I
just feel like it's like one thing after
another with Hayden Panettiere I feel so
sad for her I feel so sad for her too
just like so much tragedy and this story
is
so upsetting yeah
I just she hasn't spoken out about this
so maybe she's taking time I mean she's
can take as much time as she needs but I
just imagine you speak out a lot she's
like weirdly private too but she just
has so much that goes on that like gets
in the news because it's like it's one
thing after another yeah yeah exactly so
this is so bad for her such a sad loss
and they really there's a picture of
them they look so much alike actually
yeah they do it's really cute it's
really sad I I hope she's okay because I
know she's struggled a lot and now
something like this is just like so
devastating yeah Beyond uh he was like
found in his
New York apartment over President's Day
weekend a friend went to check on him
because he didn't show up to a business
meeting and upon arrival they found him
sitting upright in a chair unresponsive
First Responders were called and they
eventually pronounced him dead it based
on what I read it didn't seem like there
was any Foul Play Foul Play or anything
like surrounding the situation so weird
just like a heart condition for a 28
year old
and no previous like mention maybe there
was this but they didn't mention in the
article um no previous mention issues
other issues yeah I really I hope she's
okay like I hope she's
you know taking time to process because
that's really sad it's so hard and the
parents too to lose a child terrible
yeah our fifth and final story
um Tommy Fury stuns Jake Paul with a
split decision win in Saudi Arabia Jake
Paul let me tell you why this is
interesting
get the details give the details first
except I know now I know Jake Paul was
fighting yeah wait so Jake Paul who won
Tommy
okay Jake Paul's first fight against a
true boxer didn't go as planned Tommy
Fury handed the YouTube return boxer the
first loss of his career on Sunday night
in Saudi Arabia Fury Tommy Fury beat
Jake Paul via a split decision in the
eight round bow despite being knocked
down in the final round the judges
scored at 76-73 twice for Fury and 75-74
once for Paul Paul said after the fight
that he didn't agree with the judge's
decision that he both got sick and that
he both got sick twice in Camp and
injured his arm statements that Drew
lose from the crowd but I lost he said
I'm not making excuses I'm just saying
it was my best performance I fell flat
okay what was this supposed to be and
then what was it
so Tommy Fury
you're gonna love this and I feel like
you're now gonna become obsessed with
his wife like I know you are him and his
wife met on love Island
oh my God okay I'm starting to see
something else that I saw Molly Molly
May and they just had a baby literally
I've seen I feel like Bambi's Nursery
it's gorgeous I I don't even know Molly
or Tommy I know Bambi's Nursery that's
what the first thing I saw and then I
saw a video last night of Molly in her
bedroom with the baby she couldn't even
bring herself to watch the fight I
didn't know what fight I just assumed
her husband's a boxer and he fights and
her friend like runs in is like he won
and she's so happy but I didn't know
that
Jake Paul was involved or that was like
the biggest fight in the world today
yeah and I I feel like you would
actually really like Molly May's content
like yes yummy stuff I've gotten served
it a few times from my algorithm that
it's like a few more times and I will
follow you know what I mean yeah so
everyone was like invested of course
because like these Jake Paul fights like
always Garner huge crowd like all these
girls who love love Island were like so
invested in this fight last night and
these two have been like rumored to have
been fighting for so long like it was
very anticipated and this is the first
time that AJ Paul lost but it's also the
first time he went up against someone
who is like an actual trained boxer so
in the past he's like done former
athletes remember he did that former
Nick I think his name is Nate but didn't
he fight Floyd Mayweather that's Logan
oh
yeah so everyone's like well he's not a
real boxer and that's what's cool I feel
like we're always talking about how like
influencers are always you know
kind of infiltrating other spaces and we
always say like the cream Rises so you
can't be mad that like you know your
favorite influencer is doing Red Carpet
interviews and this journalism major
never got the opportunity but you know
what if you stink you stink and say what
you want about Jake Paul like he's
really gotten this huge audience for
boxing that I don't feel like they
previously really cared and this is like
a great Testament to that so even though
he lost like I feel like it's still like
a kind of a win for him it was such a
big deal everyone was talking about it
also the numbers of the loss that I'm
seeing it was lost by two points I don't
know boxing scores but that doesn't it
seems like he put up a good fight even
once he didn't get knocked out one judge
at one point rolls in his favor like it
seems respectable yeah he didn't get
knocked out it was a respectful loss he
he made an impact
um Logan Paul was asked like if he
thought it was fair and Logan was like
yeah it was fair and I actually like
really respected that answer because
it's so easy to be like no my brother
was wrong like he deserved to win so I I
didn't watch it because I was on the
plane and like I just saw everyone
tweeting about it and I was like kind of
getting invested especially when I
realize that this is the love Island
couple and that's why like everyone I
follow was like talking about this okay
but like so this guy Tommy fury like was
a really big famous boxer and went on
love Island I don't think so I'm not
entirely sure how he like plays in he is
a boxer I don't know if he became a
boxer afterwards
um I'm not sure I'd like to or did he
become like a big famous one after love
island did his favorite violent help him
with boxing I don't know sound up in the
comments like chicken and egg was like
yeah why would a big boxer go on love
Island unless he wasn't like that big
yet especially like Molly and Tommy are
like so big in the UK I think they're
kind of like the Trista and you know
whoever whatever that guy
Ryan because like they they're married
they have a kid and like people just
really like loved following them ever
since
they left the show and they're really a
testament to like the show can work it's
really like giving like Bachelor the
first first lady and and whatever Molly
Tommy and Bambi should perform at the
combination carbonation combination yeah
they should they're so British yeah okay
I'm gonna go stalk them now so there's
like a lot of elements it's like why
anyone would care about this because
like it's weirdly very like sieved in
pop culture yeah but like do you think
is Tommy you clearly don't know a lot
about his like no it's like was he is he
fighting Jake Paul just because they're
both like influencer boxers but then I
saw like Dave Portner posted a video
that he was so wrong and that Joe Rogan
like he had talked about it on Joe Rogan
and Joe Rogan said like Tommy's gonna
win so it's like Joe Rogan and he's
really big into fighting if he knows
Tommy fury like he must not just be like
an influencer fighter no he definitely
like is a well-respected and trained
boxer
yeah yeah like on Wikipedia it says he's
a boxer
oh he took time off from his boxing
career in 2019 to Star on love Island
maybe
in the UK like gets real celebrities
because it's that big there because it's
huge and it's even big here everybody
watches love Island UK
um on in boxing in 2018
and in 2019 he starred in love Island so
he had had a a career prior
love Island was the whole country like
oh my god Tommy Fury is on love island
or they were like oh this guy Tommy he's
a boxer yeah
yeah I I don't know if he was like that
famous before but maybe decently
yeah very cool
that you could be a professional boxer
and like not famous that's what I'm
saying like you can identify as a boxer
yeah no it's a really interesting kind
of way to get famous I love this for
everyone like I feel like it's it's been
like a global event that I had no idea
about I know
the rest of the club was so exciting I
love that for the globe yeah like it was
star-studded everyone was out there and
it's really you know bringing Americans
and British together and it was in the
Middle East like right now it's a global
there global Affair it's gone global
it has
um and those are the past five stories
that I feel like you really needed to
know like actually yeah I think so too
our pink lemonade collab with Lauren
Bostick spritzociety.com TSC check it
out I hope you guys enjoy it and love it
make sure to tag us when you get it and
take pics of it it's so good
um that's our show
love you dearly thank you so much for
listening to are you gonna say something
I was gonna say I love you dearly turdy
if I could
you can love you dearly turdy thank you
so much for listening to the Chelsea
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
past five stories you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast any podcast can be found on
Spotify iTunes Republican video
Everybody cast box all the places five
star review I met a beautiful standing
and what goodly talented we are hope you
guys have an enclave day we'll see you
tomorrow for Tuesday see you then bye
love ya bye